only one game in town these days the
presidential runoff vote on May the 28th
politicians are paying close attention
to the next moves of Voters like tunjay
and Burak
they both voted for independent
candidate sinan Awan in the first round
but now that Awan is out of the next
round they have to choose between
incumbent president Rajiv taib erdogan
an opposition Challenger Kamal
kilishtarolu so have you decided who
you're going to vote for
we haven't actually decided yet we're
watching developments and listening to
sinan's reasoning so will you only vote
for somebody
synonym
s
we'll vote for the candidate who we feel
will govern best for the Republic and
people that sentiment may explain the
strategy of the governing Justice and
development or Arc party
I declare my support for rejective
erdogan in the second round and call
upon my voters to support him the art
party may have secured Iran's
endorsement but it's looking Beyond him
to get votes
the lack of certainty over just how
wedded some voters are to the opposition
figures and parties they voted for in
the first round is perhaps what's
motivating the ruling Alliance now to
focus on trying to speak to the
Nationalist sentiment and trying to
reach out to those voters directly
officials are doing everything they can
to keep people singing to a familiar
tune ahead of the pole
their messaging seems to Target
nationalists
our president has long been saying
turkey has one flag one state one nation
and one Homeland this is where
nationalists and conservatives unite
analysts say sinan's endorsement of the
president for another term is a worrying
sign for the opposition it probably
since he doesn't think
on the side that is likely to lose the
main opposition Alliance is still
sounding confident though
do you think you can still win the
election sir of course
leads the rally effort for the
opposition presidential candidate the
mayor of Istanbul draws the crowds on a
visit to a market his Republican
people's party is also appealing to
nationalists promising to fight armed
groups and send refugees home
are you concerned about motivating
people to come out for the second round
the voter turnout will definitely be
high citizens understand very well
what's at stake in the second round
a nation's future is what's at stake and
in a highly polarized contest between
two players that's something many don't
want to leave to a roll of the dice
Sami zaydan Al Jazeera Istanbul